paul ollivier emilio siri avec la diact
un rêve de loi magimel pascal greggory
et samy naceri qui notre invité ce soir
alors il ya ce film là il ya le film de
gilles de maistre qui s'appelle féroce
qui sort en avril
il ya le film de laetitia masson la
repentie avec adjani qui sort également
en avril ça me ferait il ya taxi 3
qu'ils adhèrent de sortir et la mental
qui écrivent map à hambach autre ère et
réalisé par manuel boursinhac ouais
c'est beaucoup ça fait cinq films en 14
mois ça marche pour vous ouais c'est des
bons choix je crois alors samy naceri on
vous voit beaucoup mais on vous connaît
mal
on va parler de vous
alors votre père est venu d'algérie en
france bien avant l'indépendance
ils vendent et des fleurs aux halles au
départ et puis la rencontre et votre
mère normande ce qui explique les yeux
bleus sans doute il a rencontré la gare
saint lazare et eu le coup de foudre
quoi complètement sa marche vers gare
saint lazare
alors lui votre père ça me peindre en
bâtiment et vous avez une enfance
modeste comme si l'enfant dans un deux
pièces
quand même et vous arrêté l'école en 77
à l'âge de 16 ans pour partir bosser
avec votre père sur les chantiers dans
un premier temps mais vous arrêtez assez
vite quand votre père quitte votre mère
ouais tu j'aime bien parce que c'est
toujours bien au courant dans tes fiches
il présentait avec son père me perds
c'est vrai un jour il rencontre c'est à
dire internet et normandes
il rencontre qu'il a fait du bon car ils
vont mélanger l'entraîneur de son pays
rencontrent une algérienne et il part
vivre au bled avec elle voilà et il a eu
après d'ailleurs ajoute rompre avec ça
et vous avez revu votre père un jour
toscan du plantier unifrance organise un
voyage en algérie et vous allez là-bas
et vous revoyez votre père je revois mon
père on boude
au bout de 10 en emmener le taxi on n'en
menait pas mal de d'actrice on a emmené
pas mal de films est bon avec tout ce
qui s'était passé là bas ils avaient
plus de salles de cinéma plus rien donc
c'était que de la vidéo
moi j'étais là en fait pour la prochain
maxi aussi mais c'était un moment assez
incroyable cette semaine et on était
dans un signal à plein air et chaque
jour ça se remplissaient de plus en plus
élevés 5 ou 6000 personnes en plein dans
un énorme c'est comme un stade en fait
et les mecs il y avait la voiture de
taxi en fait qu'ils étaient là aussi ils
ont emmené la bagnole exemple plus rien
les mecs ils ont pu de ses amis si
j'aimerais pendant dix ans est
d'ailleurs là le cinéma et télé mode
c'était presque un an les retrouvailles
et tous étaient bien donc à vous avez eu
votre père à cette occasion alors quand
votre père s'en va quand il retourne en
algérie vous commencez un type à faire
des conneries vous dit tu traînes tu
piques une bécane ça dégénère 1
voilà et à 22 ans tu te retrouves en
taule
ouais trois ans et demi de tôle quand
même ouais pour rien en fait vous
conduisez une bagnole vous avez même pas
cap
non je faisais rien je faisais le
chauffeur et j'étais largué je me suis
retrouvé avec une équipe de veille qui
m'ont fait conduire une bagnole et ça
m'a permis de réfléchir et ça m'a permis
de de me remettre en question et puis de
me dire tiens en voyant les films à la
télé parce qu'à l'époque on a la gauche
qui nous a enlevé les parages qui nous a
mis les parloirs leed qui nous a redonné
les tenues au mitard qui ont fait pas
mal de choses et donc tu pouvais serre
et ta famille tu pouvait embrasser ta
femme tu pouvais faire pas mal de choses
et j'ai défini si j'ai bénéficié de
grâce j'ai bénéficié musée magnin shérif
en taule ouais et vous avez eu trois
mois de grâce [ __ ] t'es super bien au
courant
je sais je sais ben oui bah oui alors
voilà donc la tôle et puis alors
aujourd'hui vous êtes une star de cinéma
on vient de le dire un cinq films en 14
mois vous travaillez beaucoup vous
sortez - la nuit vous est remis au sport
vous avez rayer un certain nombre de
gens de votre agenda
et puis clarisse votre campagne vous
aide à faire le tri dans votre vie et à
virer les copains et fast on pourrait
dire ouais c'est nettoyer tout ça mais
belge et j'ai tourné faire chaud avec
des belles et belle-île manière à un
moment donné j'ai eu le même problème
que toi comme beaucoup d'acteurs
beaucoup de un moment donné tu as ta pas
mal de parasites autour de toi et il m'a
dit moi un moment donné j'ai puisque
dieu sait que belmondo a eu pas mal de
belles et jolies femmes autour de lui et
à un moment donné il a acheté un bon
extincteur et il a dit j'ai rayé et
j'espère j'ai tous les tous les
parasites cpg fit la même chose j'ai
raccroché les gants et maintenant ma
petite vie c'est la maison et le taf
vous n'êtes pas envie de décevoir
clarisse si vous n'avez pas non plus
envie de décevoir julian le fisc vous a
vu avec sally mais c'est vrai bon en
même temps vous êtes un mec de la rue
vous y pouvait rien c'est vrai que c'est
difficile de renier son passé de renier
ses amis d'enfance de leur part mais de
dos tu peux pas couper les ponts c'est
pas possible un moment donné tu vas te
retrouver dans un bar c'est ce qu'on
explique c'est ce qu'on explique dans la
mental on a écrit un film sur ce qu'on a
vu une hausse vers l'a vécu avec mon
frère est un moment donné tu peux pas
c'est pas possible tu peux pas retrouver
dans un quartier on a grandi à saint pol
on a grandi à montreuil et tu peux pas
tourner le dos mais kayes kita grandier
alors bien évidemment tu as un flic est
cachée qui prend deux photos labat en a
un autre qui est là bas qui diffuse la
série avec l'autre qu'est ce qu'il faut
avec l'autre et puis tu te retrouves
avec eux et non le toi tu fais du
cinoche alors tu les tirs la dernière
fois j'ai fait tourner un pote à moi
d'enfance qui lui il bouge pas une
oreille mais il avait envie de faire un
peu de cinoche il avait envie de voir
comment ça se passait et je vais faire
une une bonne petite silhouette ce soit
sur le film que j'ai fait c'est vrai en
même temps vous cachez pas parce que en
novembre 2000 il ya les m6 award taxi 2
meilleur film français de l'année à vous
remercier le public vous fait un bisou à
votre maman c'est normal et puis après
vous dites je voudrais dire à chaud et à
nordine que je suis avec eux ouais je
suis avec voilà bah oui et nordine
pendant ce temps là il est à la santé
vous regardez h et de la menthe aller à
sa grille c'est ce que j'ai à faire avec
avec les gens qui sont fermés non mais
ça dépend des fois ça voilà des fois
vous êtes un petit peu nerveux il
yal'affaire de l'hôtesse de l'air parce
que vous aussi comme joey starr avait
des problèmes avec les hôtesses de l'air
donc cette hôtesse de l'air vous rentrez
dans un avion à l'époque avec jean reno
et gérard krawczyk donc que vous alliez
au canada pour présenter taxi et vous
demander à être sûr qu l'assistant
classico avec votre copine et vous
demander d'être surclassée en première
et elle vous dit d'un ton comme ça un
petit peu méprisant banon mon gars tu
restes là les surclassements ça se fait
pas dans l'avion ça se fait avant alors
qu'on nous avait raconté linverse dans
l'aéroport
elle n'est pas jugée à faire tirer donc
c'est super dur d'en parler elle s'est
lâchée dans certains canards ou à la
raconter plein de conneries
l'avocat il a les papiers qu'il faut
pour pour quand on passera en jugement
je veux dire que les propos qu'il a
tenus à mon égard je veux dire quand on
dit à quelqu'un qui rentre dans un avion
j'ai mes torts et je les reconnaîtrais
au moment où il faudra et quand il le
faudra
je reconnais très - les conneries que
j'ai fait sauf que quand tu rentres dans
un avion et pictet une hôtesse de l'air
une chef de cabine qui dit ma fille m'a
dit que vous étiez un acteur formidable
un garçon charmant
je vais réfléchir je vais voir si je me
suis en classe pourquoi même dit oui ou
m d'ils en guady pas ma fille m'a dit
que ceci que seul un homme raconte sa
vie et ensuite a fini par venir
j'ai été mariée avec un arabe pendant
dix ans était mariée jeune chez mansur
qu'elle saisit les siens arrêts et
machins et ceci et cela
et je connais les arabes donc ça veut
dire qu'elle a passé une mauvaise vie
pendant 15 ans avec un art à mekla
conesa qu'elle a envie de se manger un
peu sur samy naceri mais j'aime et or
dans cette affaire connaîtra sa a été
jugée malheureusement le jour du
jugement métier pas là vous étiez en
train de tourner le film en pente
qu'ils s'appellent dj ben voilà et donc
vous avez été condamné par défaut donc
vous avez fait appel et la paire va être
va être jugé voilà samy naceri les
conneries sévigny j'ai franchement j'ai
une dit je me consacre à mon métier je
me consacre à mon fils j'en ai plein les
couilles que que monfils subissent ça et
machin donc je regardais la dernière
fois un reportage sur charlotte
gainsbourg qui parlait de son père et
tout ça je regardais les histoires de
johnny hallyday jean paul belmondo va
raconter ses histoires et je crois que
je suis pas le premier je serai pas le
dernier
je suis en train d'un peu de naviguer ce
qui me fait plaisir c'est que je suis en
train de faire ce que j'ai fait cinq
films en 14 mois
et puis que je suis en train de le
remettre bien profond